Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two. David, P..
Here's a doozy of a voicemail from this
anti-vaccine woman who keeps calling in.
This may actually be the nastiest anti-vax
call we've ever had. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 3: Okay, I forgot a word. I
remembered it. It's called aspirating.
Look at you, Mister Dr Pacman.
Speaker 1: Remember, I never claim to be
a doctor, nor to be formulating the things I say
about the vaccine on my own. I'm merely reporting
on that, which we get from epidemiologists,
immunologists, public health researchers, etc..
Speaker 3: So why do? Intra muscular
injections require. Um, God's
aspiration. Go ahead, look it up. Look it up in
any or your medical journal, Mr. Genius Pacman,
my journal is. This doctor, John
Campbell. A doctorate in nursing.
Is NADA a fluky, kooky?
Speaker 1: Yeah, by the way,
I mean, without even giving my opinion on John
Campbell, I've seen some of his videos. He has
an interesting YouTube channel. Some of his videos
are interesting to me. Some are less interesting.
He he has a Ph.D. in health science and like
the teaching of health science and a doctorate
in philosophy. So I mean, it's just we should just
mention he's not a medical doctor that that's not
praise or an attack, but even just, you know,
again, Dr. Jill Biden shouldn't be called doctor.
You be the judge. You be the judge as to when
we should use the term doctor. When we're
talking about someone who's talking
about medicine. I don't know.
Speaker 3: Always not. There are numerous studies
out there like, like you say, and there aren't
any. There's like one study out of wherever.
You're so foolish. Oh, it's listed as
one of the most essential drugs
in the World Health Organization.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I think she's talking
about ivermectin. And of course,
that doesn't mean it's works for COVID.
Speaker 3: It's written off label all the time.
You know, why would they give a dog the
same penicillin that they give a human? Why?
You know what? You know what this is all about
the show, about showing vaccinations to people and
making billions. We not only paid for the vaccines
to be developed. Now we got to pay the mothers
like big bucks.
Speaker 1: Right?
So I don't think there's any bringing her back.
I just don't think there's any bringing her back,
if you think there might be. Please
explain to me how on today's bonus show,
producer Pat makes his triumphant return. We will
hear what he's been up to. We will talk about
the resignation of NFL coach Jon Gruden after
homophobic, racist and misogynistic e-mails.
We will talk about how the New York
City Schools vaccine mandate is going,
and we will talk about the approval by the FDA of
another rapid antigen test. What's different about
this rapid test for COVID? We will discuss in
detail all of those stories on today's bonus show.
Sign up at Join Packman dot com. You can use the
coupon code better 21 to save if you want. You
don't have to. You decide. And we will speak
to you on the bonus show in mere moments.